이 경우에는 Choi 표현과의 연결을 만들기 위해서요. 이 방식으로 Choi 표현을 보는 것에서 즉시 도출할 수 있는 몇 가지 함의가 있어요.
하나는 Φ가 유효한 채널이라고 가정하면 Choi 상태가 밀도 행렬이기 때문에, Φ의 Choi 표현이 반드시 양의 반정치여야 한다는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요.
기억하세요, 채널은 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건이 있고,
이건 그 특수한 경우예요. 두 번째 함의는 임의의 채널 Φ에 대한 Choi 상태를 취하고
출력 시스템 Y를 버리면, 반드시 입력 시스템 X의 완전 혼합 상태가 남는다는 거예요.
그 이유는 시스템에 채널을 적용하고 결과 시스템을 버리는 건 원래 시스템을 그냥 버리는 것과 동등하기 때문이에요.
그리고 최대 얽힘 상태로 그렇게 하면, 남는 밀도 행렬은
n으로 나눈 항등 행렬, 즉 시스템 X에 대한 완전 혼합 상태가 될 거예요. 더 수학적인 용어로는,
임의의 채널과 출력 시스템의 대각합을 합성하면 입력 시스템의 대각합과 같아야 한다는 거예요.
채널은 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이라는 사실로 인해 대각합을 보존해야 하기 때문이에요.
이 방정식이 있으면 분모 n을 양쪽에서 제거해서
약간 더 깔끔한 조건을 얻을 수 있어요. 말로 하면, 채널의 Choi 표현에서 출력 시스템의 부분 대각합을 수행하면
반드시 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬을 얻어야 해요. 요약하면, 채널의 Choi
표현은 항상 양의 반정치이고, 출력 시스템을 trace out하면 반드시 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬이 남아요.
밝혀진 바에 따르면, 이것들은 필요 조건일 뿐만 아니라 충분 조건이기도 해요. 즉, Φ가 임의의 선형 사상이고 이 두 조건이 모두
성립한다면, Φ는 반드시 유효한 채널이에요. 강의 끝에서 왜 그런지 알게 될 거예요.
몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 완전 위상 제거 채널부터 시작해서 Choi 표현을 계산하는 건 그냥 공식을 계산하는 문제예요.
완전 위상 제거 채널은 a=b일 때 |a⟩⟨b|를 그대로 두고, 그렇지 않으면 출력이
0이에요. 그래서 합에서 살아남는 항들은 a=b인 것들이고, 결과는 화면에서 직접 표기법으로 표현돼요.
블록 행렬로도 볼 수 있어요. Delta는 대각 항목들을 그대로 두고 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만들어요.
그래서 왼쪽 위와 오른쪽 아래 모서리에 1이 있고 나머지 항목들은 모두 0인 행렬이 남아요.
이건 첫 번째 식과 일치해요. 또 다른 예시로 완전 편극 제거 채널을 고려해 봐요. 공식을 적는 것부터 시작하고,
이전 예시처럼 a가 b와 같지 않을 때는 합에 기여가 없어요.
이번에는 a=b일 때 완전 혼합 상태를 얻고, 이걸 단순화해서
1/2 * (2x2 항등 행렬의 텐서곱)을 얻는데, 이는 1/2 * 4x4
항등 행렬이에요. 블록 행렬 관점에서도 생각해볼 수 있고, 당연히 같은 결과를 얻어요.
마지막 예시로, 단일 qubit에 대한 항등 채널을 고려해 봐요. 쉬운 거예요. 공식이 여기 있고,
물론 항등 채널은 아무것도 안 해요. 결과를 Φ+ 상태와 연관된 밀도 행렬의 두 배로 생각할 수 있고,
이건 이 채널의 Choi 상태를 생각해서 기대하는 것과 일치해요. 블록 행렬로는 이렇게 돼요. 특히 항등 채널의 Choi
표현이 항등 행렬이 아니라는 점에 주목하세요. 이 행렬이에요. 이제 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 세 가지 다른
방법을 살펴봤어요. 즉 Stinespring 표현, Kraus 표현, 그리고 Choi
표현이에요. 그리고 채널의 정의도 가지고 있는데, 채널은 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용될 때도
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이에요. 이 시점에서 자연스럽고 매우 중요한 질문은,
이것들이 모두 동등하다는 걸 어떻게 알 수 있냐는 거예요. 예를 들어, 이 표현들 중 하나로 설명되는 모든 사상이
실제로 유효한 채널임을 어떻게 알 수 있고, 어떤 채널을 빠뜨리지 않았다는 걸 어떻게 알 수 있을까요?
강의의 나머지 부분에서는 이 모든 것을 수학적으로 어떻게 추론할 수 있는지 설명해요.
이것들의 동등성을 받아들이려 하고 어떻게 추론할 수 있는지에 관심이 없다면, 나머지 영상을 건너뛰어도 돼요.
하지만 저는 개인적으로 이 논증이 꽤 세련됐다고 생각하고, 양자 정보 이론에서 때때로 나오는 특정 스타일의 수학적 증명의 좋은 예라고 생각해요.
모든 세부 사항을 다루지는 않을 거예요. 일부는 여러분에게 남겨두거나, 모든 것이 자세히 적혀 있는 이번 강의의 문서에서 찾을 수 있어요.
하지만 어떻게 작동하는지 합리적으로 명확한 그림을 보여드리고 싶어요. 하려는 건 일련의 명제들의 동등성을 증명하는 거예요.
이를 위한 방법은 함의의 사이클을 설정하는 거예요. 특히 채널의 정의부터 시작할 거예요.
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이라는 의미에서요.
이 정의로부터 이 채널의 Choi 표현이 이미 논의한 두 조건을 만족해야 한다는 추론을 할 수 있고,
실제로 이미 이걸 했어요. 채널의 Choi 상태의 맥락에서 논의했어요. 그런 다음
정의에 대한 것은 모두 잊고 Choi 표현에서 작업해요. 그리고 Choi 표현에 대한 두 조건이 주어지면, 사상 Φ의 Kraus 표현이 반드시 존재한다는 결론을 내려요.
그런 다음 유사한 걸 해요. Choi 표현에 대한 건 잊고
임의의 Kraus 표현에서 작업하면, 사상 Φ에 대한 Stinespring 표현이 반드시 있다는 추론을 할 수 있어요. 그리고 이런 논증들은
어떤 의미에서 기계적이어서, 원한다면 특정 채널에 대해 화살표에 따라 변환을 실제로 수행할 수 있어요.
그렇게 하려면요. 마지막 함의는 사상 Φ에 대한 Stinespring 표현이 있으면
그 사상이 실제로 유효한 채널이어야 한다는 추론이에요. 그리고 다시 한번, 이미 그걸 했어요. 이번에는 Stinespring 표현의 맥락에서요.
이 네 가지 함의를 모두 합치면, 이 네 가지가 모두 동등하다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 어떤 것에서 시작해도
함의를 추이적으로 따라가서 나머지 것들 중 어느 것에도 도달할 수 있기 때문이에요. 첫 번째 함의부터 시작할 거예요.
채널 Φ, 즉 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이 있으면, Choi
표현이 앞서 확인한 두 조건을 만족한다는 거예요. 즉 양의 반정치이고
출력 시스템을 trace out하면 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬을 얻는다는 거예요. 방금 전에 언급했듯이,
이미 Choi 상태의 맥락에서 이 함의를 다뤘어요. 특히 채널의 Choi 표현을 n, 즉 입력 시스템의
고전적 상태 수로 나누면 밀도 행렬을 얻고, 게다가 입력 시스템의 축소된 상태는
그 상태에서 시스템 X는 완전 혼합 상태, 즉 n으로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요. 분모를 제거하면 두 조건을 얻어요.
두 조건이에요. 그래서 이 함의는 이미 다뤘기 때문에 꽤 빠르고 쉬워요.